welcome rain on this blackened land just
west of Sydney it's not the first
downpour since the fire season began
last year but it's reduced the number of
active Blazers and as bringing relief to
areas gripped by the worst drought on
record but the deluge is also sweeping
piles of ash soot and other debris into
rivers lakes and dams that provide
drinking water to those living nearby
we've never had an experience like this
before during the bush pilot period look
we had over three hundred and
eighty-five thousand hectares of the
catchment actually burned and that those
fires actually came down to the water
line so it's a significant impact the
bush fires I've had across there
this is Warragamba dam it supplies 80
percent of Sydney's drinking water but
could be contaminated by charred debris
from the vast bush fires in the area
scientists say it probably won't cause
any health problems but authorities
aren't taking any chances
they've put in silk curtains to catch
any material that could affect water
quality and are monitoring the situation
closely
contaminated water isn't just a problem
for humans small pieces of ash from
trees like this can get into the
waterways and suffocate the fish they
can also cause algal blooms which can
produce dangerous toxins or cut the
amount of oxygen in the water they can
put other wildlife at risk thousands of
fish died in January when brains washed
sludge into the Makai River in New South
Wales and late last year piles of ash
clogged the beaches as fires raged
nearby many bush fires are still burning
up and down this coastline leaving
waterways and water supplies at risk it
takes decades for a forest to regrow and
to re-stabilize we will be dealing with
different quality water different
organic matter coming down higher
sediment loads for many years and I
would predict in many cases certainly in
Sydney's case decades new growth is
beginning to push through the scorched
landscape but the cost of this
unprecedented fire
season is mounting and it's not over yet
Alexia O'Brien al-jazeera New South
Wales Australia